this video is sponsored
by playstation
you've probably heard that a demon souls
remake is one of the core launch titles
for the playstation 5.
you've also probably heard that demon
souls is
quite difficult we're here to tell you
though
don't let that intimidate you and
certainly don't let it put you off
playing
if you're an early adopter of a ps5 this
is a launch game
that you're going to want to see for
yourself
the thing about demon souls is yes it's
challenging
but it is almost always fair and it does
tend to reward players who pay attention
are patient and are willing to learn
from their mistakes to
get up and try and die
and try again if you've been putting off
the opportunity to get stuck
into your very first souls experience
this stunningly beautiful and
incredibly faithful demon souls remake
by blue point games
is a perfect time to get stuck in follow
our handy guide and you too will be an
expert slayer of demons
in no time
[Music]
it might feel a little overwhelming when
you first start a game of demon souls
and are immediately presented with the
choice of which character class you want
to play as
but bear in mind here that classes are
really only a starting point affecting
your first
few hours of play and you can customize
your build
however you see fit later on down the
line of course
your class does set the tone for how you
approach combat early on
so the night soldier and temple knight
are good choices for beginners wanting
to focus on physical combat
as they have a solid point spread for
offense and defense
and come armed with decent weapons to
boot however if you want a
slightly easier time in the earlier
stages of your adventure
the royal class is a must as it will
give you instant access to the sole
arrow spell
this allows you to deal considerable
damage to enemies from a safe distance
not only that but the royal class also
comes equipped with a fragrant ring that
regenerates mp over time
making for a powerful ready-to-use magic
wielder who
effectively has unlimited casting
ability
remember though there's really no wrong
class to go for
you can spend your souls to increase
stats however you wish in the nexus
changing and evolving your character to
specialize in whatever you like going
forward
you can buy spells for your knight or
put points into your magician so they
can wield even the mightiest of great
swords or hal beds
there are only a few items that are
restricted to certain classes so
relax experiment and find out what works
best for you
we do recommend however that you pick
the providential ring as your special
starting gift
it improves your luck and increases drop
rates for healing items
which will be a big help early on
especially if you're playing as a melee
class
all of the other starting gifts are
consumables meaning they'll be gone and
used up
in no time and eventually can be found
elsewhere in the game
anyway so you're off the tutorial area
a gentle run-up to an encounter with the
not-so-gentle vanguard demon
is a great place to practice some key
combat moves
take your time here and get comfortable
with the mechanics
in particular parrying reposting and
backstabbing
most humanoid enemies in the game will
be susceptible to reposts and backstabs
which can deal massive damage and make
otherwise difficult fights
much more manageable but every enemy has
a slightly different bite point for when
exactly to press l2 to repel their
attack
and where exactly you should be
positioned behind them to initiate a
successful backstab animation with
r1 another essential skill set to get
comfortable with is the game's
omnidirectional dodge rolling
both when you're locked onto an enemy
with r3 and when you're freely moving
about the world
rolling is an often life-saving maneuver
so you should practice it in the early
stages as
much as you can to get comfortable with
its timing but
on that note pay close attention to the
equipment and item burdens
and depending on your character's level
of endurance you'll find that your
inventory will eventually begin
to seriously slow your movement making
your dodge rolling
obsolete or stop you from picking
anything else up
luckily with this remake blue point has
mercifully changed things
so that when you reach your item carry
limit you'll have the option to send
items directly into storage
instead of leaving them out there on the
field you still want to avoid this if
possible as it will mean you won't be
able to equip that life-saving ring
or piece of armor if you need to but at
least it means that you won't have to
make
multiple trips back into hostile
territory just to pick up what you
missed
get into the habit of reorganizing and
rearranging your item and equipment
loadout every time you return to the
nexus
and travel lights wherever possible
because as well as your hit points
you absolutely must learn to keep an eye
on your stamina
that's the green bar below your red
health bar in the top left hand corner
of your screen
stamina in a souls game is almost as
important as your hp
especially if you're playing a melee
class stamina allows you to run
dodge attack and block incoming damage
with a shield
so when you're in a fight with multiple
enemies doing all these things
simultaneously
stamina is easily drained in no time at
all
now if you choose a night class you
automatically start the game equipped
with the fluted armor set
this is great for protecting you from
incoming damage but it also means that
from the outset
you'll be doing something known in the
souls community as fat rolling
this means that due to your equipment
weighing more than 50 percent of your
overall equipment allowance
rolling and dodging takes far longer
leaving you open
and vulnerable to attacks some players
don't mind this preferring to stand
still
and tank damage with a shield but to
make things easier on yourself
and be a bit nimbler on your feet
consider either equipping
a different set of armor as soon as you
possibly can
or immediately starting to invest levels
into your character's endurance stat
to improve their overall carrying and
equipment capacity
when you die for the first time in demon
souls either to the vanguard or to
another special someone if you manage to
survive that fight
you'll end up in the nexus a sort of hub
world where a lot of the game's useful
npcs come to hang out
get accustomed to coming back here often
because regularly checking in and
interacting with a couple of key
characters is crucial for staying on top
of your game
first you have the maiden in black who
will trade your hard-earned souls for
improvements to vital stats
like strength intelligence stamina and
dexterity
the blacksmith will trade those same
souls for weapon repairs and upgrades
but be on the lookout for a second
blacksmith in the first area behind the
archstone of the digger king
he can provide you with even more
powerful weapon upgrades
you'll find him by staying on a lift for
longer than you need to
additionally other characters in the
nexus will sell you spells or miracles
and you might even encounter more lost
souls on your adventure who end up back
here too
to trade or offer up new bits of lore or
scraps of information
but be careful not all who wander into
your midst are trustworthy
but hell at least the demons don't send
us to our deaths in battle
after your initial exploration of
boletaria castle you don't have to visit
the archstones in
any particular order once you've
defeated the game's official
first boss for lancs and spoken to a
special npc
hidden within the nexus the other
archstones will open up and you can
attempt any world
in any order bear in mind too that you
don't need to and
often shouldn't complete each world in
one straight shot
there are fast travel checkpoints that
appear after you defeat each boss
so once you complete a stage and slay
its demon you can use the checkpoint to
return to the nexus
level up repair and enhance your
equipment and then either return to that
world to continue your journey there
or change things up and explore a
different archstone
it's definitely a good idea to move
around and try out all the different
stages
especially if you find yourself
struggling with a particular area
you may find that a change in location
will make things more manageable
and it might even provide you with
weapons rings or equipment
that will ease your passage through
other worlds get used to not
having a full health bar running around
with full health and demon souls
is really a bit of a luxury when you die
and
we do mean when your overall hp is
reduced by half as long as you're in
your so-called
soul form your body and thus full health
is only restored after defeating a boss
or using an initially rare item called
stone of ephemeral eyes
however obtaining the cling ring fairly
early on in the game
increases your maximum health from 50 to
while in your soul form you'll find this
handy item on a corpse at the bottom of
the first tower
in world one one after a short cut back
to your starting area is opened you'll
want to have this deceptively simple
piece of hardware equipped
to one of your two precious ring slots
even after your jewelry selection
becomes a bit more robust
whenever you discover a hidden pathway
or exploit an enemy's weakness or
even just decide to share a simple
musing with the world consider leaving a
message for
all the players coming along behind you
messages can make the
often stressful trek across these
hostile lands feel a little less lonely
you can only choose phrases and words
from preset templates
which makes for often abstract but very
funny communications from players just
like you
who need a moment of encouragement or
respite
messages that point the way forward to a
boss or a healing item or a piece of
treasure can save
lives including yours when others rate
your message fair while playing the game
you'll get an immediate health boost
that can turn the tables of whatever
conflict you find yourself in the midst
of
a little miracle saint urbain himself
would be proud of
really though our final and best tip for
taking on demon souls is to do it at a
gentle pace
be patient take your time and explore
return to the nexus and level up
often take each new area as it comes
hang back and watch your foes attack
patterns instead of launching into an
aggressive offensive
the game rewards players who take a more
analytical or strategic approach to
things
there's almost always an opportunity or
a window for you to move in and perform
a parry or a backstab
so long as you think before you act and
never go barrelling around a corner
without considering what
might be waiting on the other end play
demon souls your way
except that trial and error is a part of
the experience and enjoy it
[Music]
[Applause]
playstation